In this section, I'm going to walk you through lighting a scene from scratch.
My aim is to create a scene that feels more natural in nature as opposed to something
more overly stylized, so I will be adjusting parameters to be more in line with natural
earth-based science.
However, you are more than welcome to and I encourage you to take artistic liberties
with everything we're building in this class, so you can better understand what
each of the parameters does and how you can manipulate them to achieve in the look
and feel you want.
So for this exercise, we're going to start with our Lit Atmos in-class map, which is
located in our Content Maps folder.
So if you open that, one thing we want to do is either disable or delete the existing
post-processing volume.
So in this case, I'm just going to hide it, and this should allow us to start from
scratch.
So the first thing I want to do is go up to Window, Environment Light Mixer, which
again if you've been following, you understand what this is doing.
So we're going to create a skylight, directional light, sky atmosphere, volumetric cloud, and
our height fog.
And within our height fog, so if I scroll down, I'm going to check volumetric fog.
We'll go ahead and close this.
So this will give us our base component, so I'm just going to select those actors,
and I'm going to group them, and we'll just call this Environment or Lighting, whatever
you want.
Just something where we can keep them contained together.
And I'm going to leave all the defaults as is.
I'm going to press Control-L real quick and just move our light, so we can kind of
see a little bit that it is working within our scene, but of course, the scene is very
dark.
So I'm going to go back to our Place Actors, and I'm just going to search for post.
I'm going to find a post-processing volume, add it into our scene, and I'm going
to scroll down.
I'm going to make sure that our Infinite Extent Unbound is checked, have that, go back
up to our Exposure, set our Min and Max EV by checking them to 1, do this, and our
Exposure Compensation to, I think about 8 should be good to get our scene lit.
Now real quick, if you notice something, I'm going to uncheck these real fast and uncheck
our Min and Max EV.
If I reset this, you'll notice that the scene starts to progressively get brighter.
And by doing this, again, you can absolutely feel free to, with the Min and Max EV,
it's going to assess the overall scene and try to hit your Min and your Max EV.
But in this case, why we are setting it to 1 and 1 is we are clamping it.
So Exposure Compensation, Min and Max Clamped, it means whether we're looking at a dark
spot or a bright spot, the exposure is going to be fixed.
Okay, so all of that makes sense.
All right, so now that we can kind of see our scene a little bit, again, I'm going
to take our light and just move it around to give me something that artistically
looks kind of fun.
Just looking for some highlights and some shadows within our scene, and I'll use that
for now.
I'm going to go ahead and press G to go into Game Mode because I want to kind of just
see our scene as is.
And the first thing that I want to do is just kind of start adjusting my initial light.
So this is going to be our sunlight.
So I'm going to select our directional light.
I could choose to adjust intensity.
I'm not going to touch light color or the temperature because again, because we're
using all of these different components together, it's going to handle the light coloration
based off of the light position.
So again, if I do Ctrl L and kind of lower this to something like sunset, you'll see
that it does start to adjust that overall color, keep it just as is.
But I do want to start kind of playing with some of our volume metrics.
So if I take my volume metric scattering intensity to zero, the first thing that I want
to do is adjust my bounce.
So if I keep this at one, I'm obviously viewing the information being injected from our volumetric
scattering.
I don't want that right now.
So our indirect lighting intensity, which we haven't really covered up to this point,
has to do with the balanced lighting.
So Lumen handles this exceptionally well.
But you'll notice that inside of this cave, we have a lot of light sources kind of injecting
information to our scene, but we have this really dark, or I should say darker, kind of
ceiling within this cave.
I can adjust the indirect lighting intensity to something like five, and so now I get
a lot more boost, and that made me a little bit too much.
Maybe I'd add this back down to two.
So now I just get a little bit more light propagating into our scene.
All right, so now we can reset our volumetric scattering intensity.
I've got that back into our scene.
And maybe what I want to do here is adjust the fog settings itself.
So I'm going to jump over to our exponential height fog.
And again, I can adjust the fog density, get something that looks really, really robust,
maybe really rich.
For the purposes of this, I'm going to take it to something like, actually go to 0.05
just to give a little bit more boost.
I'm not going to worry about secondary fog data just because this is a small interior
scene.
I can't really see the results here unless we were outside.
And then the other thing I want to do is go down to our volumetric fog.
Scattering distribution I think is fine at 0.2, leave my albedo, and maybe I adjust
my extinction scale.
Maybe I take it down.
I think for now, though, I'm going to leave it at one.
All right.
The other thing I'm going to do now is jump back to our directional light.
And I'm going to kind of just kind of zoom around our scene, just take a look at
it as a whole.
I've got a lot of these really cool kind of just god rays piercing through my scene,
which I like.
But I feel like maybe this is kind of not as realistic as I want.
I have a lot more bounce lighting happening around here because of our volumetric.
So I'm going to go back to our directional light.
I'm going to scroll down, and I'm going to turn on light shaft occlusion.
So in this case, I may, I actually don't mind the 0.5.
I think that works well.
But if I wanted to bring some of that back, maybe I increase it to something like, we'll
say 0.5.
I'm going to check it off on, again, adjust as you see fit.
Light shaft bloom.
Again, I really do like this effect, however, I don't like the effect in its current state
because it's a little blown out.
So I'm going to set my bloom scale to something like 0.1.
So again, I'll check this off and on just to show what that's doing.
Turn my bloom max brightness to something like 2.
Uncheck, check.
See, it's very subtle.
Maybe we increase this a little bit more, maybe do something like 10.
So again, there we go.
So now I've got some of that bloom occurring, which again, just feels a little bit more
natural.
All right, at this juncture, I would say that we're in a state where we could do
some balancing.
But what I'm going to do is just kind of view our scene as it would go through different
just kind of like time.
So I'm going to click back into our viewport, hold Control-L, zoom up here.
Right, and I may go into some, you know, again, this is more of like a high noon.
And maybe I'll go into something more like a sunset, we go back something that's more
like backlit, right.
And at this juncture, you can go in and adjust the settings.
So from my artistic perspective, artistic interpretation is I do feel like the volumetrics are
a little heavy.
So the first place that I would start is with the light actor itself.
So again, you can see volumetric scattering intensity is at one.
Now this was something that was kind of custom adjusted.
So say I had something like three, right, this would probably be a logical place to
start because with one, we are simply just using the values from our volumetric fog,
as opposed to overriding those.
Now I could, let's just say hypothetically that, you know, the rest of my scene looks
great.
It's just my sunlight.
I could lower the volumetric scattering intensity, say something like 0.5 within the light here,
and you'll see that it kind of lessens that overall effect.
But in this case, I'm gonna set it back to one.
I'm gonna go back to our exponential height fog.
And maybe in here, I'm just gonna set my fog density down just a little bit more,
or even look at my extinction scale.
So again, I could do something like 0.5 to lower it back to one.
And hopefully you're understanding the different properties and parameters you would adjust
to tweak that.
Go back to here, just kind of start playing with it, you know, again, so I really like
this look, but in for tweaking purposes, let's just say that, you know, maybe these
god rays are a little intense.
We've already confirmed on our exponential height fog extinction scale.
All that is kind of set to the default.
So not really worried about there.
But within our directional light, we can adjust.
Let's go back down to our light shaft seclusion and our bloom scale.
Let's see if it's bloom.
Bloom definitely does make a difference, light shafts, again, maybe we could, you know, darken
this a little bit more.
So it's not as much.
And then again, we could change our volumetric scattering intensity, something like 0.2,
and you see that it lowers.
So again, hopefully, that kind of showcases a little bit.
And then lastly, once once I've got my scene set up where I do like the lighting,
I like how it's propagating, we can go in and adjust additional settings within our
post processing volume.
Again, I'm not going to step through every single one of the properties within here.
But I do recommend you play with it because there's a lot of cool features and a lot
of things that we can do to further refine our look even further.
I will show a couple examples here.
But again, feel free to play with this, adjust it, do whatever you need to.
Something that we could do, I'm just going to go into our global.
And let's just say that I take my contrast and I ramp this up.
You see, I can get a different effect.
I can lower the contrast, flatten out the scene a little bit.
I'll reset this.
We do have individualized controls, say, for example, within our shadows.
Maybe I want to increase the gamma of my shadows.
So I'm going to take this all the way down so you can crunch these values.
You'll see that it's only targeting our dark, our shadowed areas.
If I take this up, so let me reset it back to 1.
And I take this up, you'll see that I can kind of give some,
I'll call it faked, kind of building up our lowers.
But again, you have to be careful, because as we adjust our scene,
you'll see that it can affect everything over the whole scene.
So here's checked, unchecked, et cetera.
But again, if you're familiar with just color grading workflow,
you'll be right at home in this section.
But again, feel free to just check things, test it,
and see what's going on here.
Maybe I want to do some weird colorations, whatever it is.
Go for it.
Because this is our post-processing volume, it's non-destructive, right?
So I can always just reset, go back.
I can add a new post-processing volume, whatever we need to, good to go.
Last thing I want to cover on this one,
again, this will depend on the hardware that you're running on,
but is to also check some of the global illumination.
So here we have lighting quality, scene detail.
This will probably be a little bit more evident when you do have some very
harsh lighting coming in, so if I kind of move this around here,
where we can really see global illumination taking effect,
is to go through and play with some of these settings.
So for example, Lumen Scene Detail.
Now, I know this does pop off screen, but it says,
control the size of instances that can be represented in Lumen Scene.
Larger values will ensure smaller objects are represented,
but increase GPU costs.
Because we have all these little surface details here
and some smaller assets,
I may want to bump this Lumen Scene Detail up to, say, for example, 4.
Watch my performance.
And again, go through all these and look
at how the parameter, the settings, will affect the visual quality.
And then also keeping in mind, now I have monitor editor performance
turned on for my FPS.
I could also use something like, go up to here,
we can go to viewport stats, and we could look up like FPS and RHI.
Actually, let me just turn off RHI.
We'll just use FPS.
So we can see the overall performance.
So again, as you start adjusting some of these things, cranking it up,
look at the performance cost within your editor.
In the next video, we'll briefly talk about the new day sequence
feature included in Unreal Engine 5.6.